also aus heutiger sicht betrachtet hätte
ich sicherlich anders gemacht weil ich
weiß aber auch dass es damals nicht
anders ging
also das war sozusagen tatsächlich dass
der die der letzte moment nach einer
unbeschreiblichen zeitlang manche sagen
auch mediale hetzjagd oder einfach einer
zeit die extrem war unter einem extremen
druck und trotzdem ja auch immer zu
hause noch nie gesagt eben auch eine
familie zusammenhalten wollen und auch
freunde und so und mir gedacht habe ich
das ich kann das alles irgendwie nicht
mehr übereinander bekommen eine mischung
aus totaler überforderung und
erleichterung dass es vorbei ist und
dann auch letztlich auch ein gefühl von
4 300 fotografen und journalisten ihr da
jetzt wie eine wand steht ihr bekommt
kein gefühl von mir zu sehen so und das
ging dann nicht mehr also gedacht sodass
gehört wirklich nur mir her
das bleibt bei mir und das wirkte nach
außen auf viele kalt ist dann ist
lanciert genauso hab ich habe gedacht
dass das bekommt ihr nicht auch noch von
uns ihr habt jetzt versucht uns
sozusagen jetzt zu bringen
wir haben es geschafft das bekommt er
nicht und was hätten sie heute anders
gemacht wenn es der tag heute war ich
hätte wahrscheinlich wenn ich wenn ich
da jetzt mit mehr abstand oder mit einem
großem abstand an den tag zurückdenke
dann wäre es mir wahrscheinlich jetzt
möglich trotzdem auch noch natürlicher
sozusagen mit der situation umzugehen
ja tatsächlich ich hätte wahrscheinlich
ich hätte mehr emotionen zeigen können
ich wäre jetzt sicherlich nicht mit
meinem damaligen mann nochmals gefallen
weil alles so fürchterlich ist aber
sondern das einfach zu zeigen das ist
natürlich mich und uns extrem
mitgenommen hat das ist menschlich
einfach nicht mehr zu ertragen war auch
und ich glaube das hätte der ganzen
sache auch ganz gut getan und ich glaube
das würde sowieso mal ein bisschen
schwenker zu kriegen
sowieso politik ganz gut tun wenn und
dafür wäre jetzt eigentlich auch eine
gute zeit wenn man auch betrachten würde
dass das eben menschen sind und dass es
um menschliche reaktionen geht so das
sind personen die versuchen es so gut
wie möglich zu machen
aber es sind eben auch menschen und die
funktionieren nicht einfach
[Musik]